bonsoir
traque un peu un petit peu c'est normal
chope à tout va bien je suis d'être là
je suis ravi que vous soyez là tout va
très bien se passer vous avez vu ma
fille est partie vous êtes du pot il me
dérange pas et vous dérange pas très
bien si vous connaissez luc ferry donc
été quittée ministre de l'éducation
nationale de la recherche des
universités de la jeunesse des draps en
satin des rolls royce
à tous et arielle dombasle qui a fait 1
10 formidable s'appelle amor amor un
réel et qui fait l'olympia c'est
incroyable ça quand on est ravis pour
vous alors cynthia vous êtes la fille de
michel sardou donc et vous publié aux
éditions du rocher un livre bouleversant
une autobiographie qui s'appelle
appelez-moi lille ou alors lille où
c'est un nom qui vous a été donné par un
parent un ami et aujourd'hui c'est votre
nouveau nom oui un site une c'est une
façon de faire la transition une
transition de ma vie
suite à tout ce qui s'est passé et tout
ce que j'ai vécu en 30 ans
lille ou c
oui ça fait partie du changement de ma
vie parce que j'ai décidé de
de laisser derrière moi tout ce qui
convenait pas voilà alors vous êtes la
fille cynthia de la première épouse de
michel sardou françoise pétré qui à
l'époque était danseuse au châtelet vous
êtes né en 1973 en même temps que romain
sardou nous avons reçues souvent ici
alors à l'époque où vous n'essayez donc
de l'épousé de michel sardou romain
n'essaie de babette qui à l'époque
n'était pas encore la femme n'était pas
encore la deuxième femme de michel
sardou mais était sa maîtresse et sa
moins en moins d'écart voilà voilà alors
michel voulait un garçon est de toute
évidence c'était pas vous c'était pas
moi c'était pas moi et je pense que
bon je l'est
comment expliquer ça dès que j'ai de mon
père j'étais une erreur quoi oui je le
pense sincèrement et je d'ailleurs je
n'ai pas honte de ce que j'ai écrit je
n'ai pas honte de ce que je suis
aujourd'hui parce que je suis une fille
et je suis ravi d'être une fille
tellement parce que les garçons à
l'époque voila voila moi excusez moi et
alors votre mère vous en à votre mère
vous on a voulu en fait parce qu'elle a
la pensée elle s'est imaginé que le fait
que vous soyez une fille à aider michel
à se séparer d'elle en faites vous un
petit peu rendu responsable on y perçoit
dire on est toujours persuadé
aujourd'hui oui oui oui parce que j'ai
d'ailleurs il ya une lettre qui me le
prouve justement et que je que je que
j'intègre dans l'histoire donc
effectivement je même trente ans après
vous voyez c'est visiblement cessé
rester et vous donc vous avez grandi
avec ce sentiment de culpabilité
c'est à dire que vous vous sentiez un
petit peu responsables de leur rupture
je me suis complètement senti
responsable de cette rupture déjà parce
que j'ai
j'ai pas vécu je peux pas dire que j'ai
eu une enfance parce que j'en ai pas eu
mon père a effectivement
donné ce qu'il fallait pour notre
éducation en revanche
moi je ne me concerne je ne considère
pas avoir reçu d'éducation je me suis
éduquer tout seul je m'étais créé un
monde à moi dans ma tête un monde
merveilleux qui m'a permis de résister
absolument à tous c'est à dire dans mon
mental c'est mon mental qui a fait que
j'ai résisté à toute la violence
que que j'aime bien à l'époque où vous
naissez michel sardou est en train de
devenir une méga vedette vraiment une
star nationale est en fait vous décrivez
l'envers du décor c'est à dire que par
exemple dont il est très sympa comme ça
que tu es avec des gens et quand il à la
maison mais un cendrier qui est déplacé
il rentre dans une colère noire il lance
des regards absolument terrible au genre
enfin c'est oui
il est il est comme ça après son divorce
michel sardou épouse babette donc sa
seconde épouse et votre mère épouse
dites-vous un pseudo producteur de
musique que vous ne que vous ne citez
pas vous donnait pas son nom et lui est
intéressé en fait par les relations de
votre mère par le carnet d adresse de
votre mère par l'argent que votre père
versa votre mère mais en fait vous
l'appelez le funeste d'ailleurs ça sera
jamais quelqu'un de positif pour vous en
tous les cas c'est d'ailleurs je tiens à
priziac pour moi il s'agit bien d'un
criminel en liberté ce n'est pas autre
chose c'est un personnage taille parce
qu'il exige que vous l'appeliez papa
mais il vous bas ils vous battra pendant
des années en fait pendant ben j'ai vécu
dans cet entourage pendant plus de 15
ans oui donc quand vous vivez ça tous
les jours et igm ans et il ya un moment
il faut partir il faut s'en aller mais
votre mère dit rien
ben visiblement non elle est je dirais
que c'est ma mère était une absente
une absente avec un grand a et il n'y a
pas je pense que quand on aime quelqu'un
l'amour parfois peut aller si loin qu'on
on en est un est aveugle de tout ce qui
se passe autour et je pense que oui et
là c'était un moyen pour elle de le
garder que d'accepter ce qu il vous
faisait subir en fait
peut-être
qu'envoyer michel sardou ça se passe pas
mieux parce que vous voyez très peu mais
quand vous voyez par exemple une fois
vous avez 5 ans il est très dur avec
vous un jour vous refuser d'aider
d'évacuer la salle de bains et vous
traite de tas de merde quand même quoi
oui c'est vrai c'est vrai j'avais 5 ans
et je m'en rappelle pas c'est d'ailleurs
c'est même étonnant mais la psychanalyse
à faire remonter encore des choses à la
surface parce qu'on croit toujours tout
est enfoui et qu'on oublie mais en fait
c'est en soit ce
et après ça il s'est pas excusé quoi
michel sardou s'excuse rarement
général alors les bons moments
finalement c'est avec votre grand mère
jackie sardou alors là ça se passe super
bien à quoi c'est vraiment quelqu'un de
boer
oui qui a été très présente et
d'ailleurs même dans des contextes je
dirais
complètement loufoque parce qu'elle
était elle à el alami le scandale dans
un restaurant un jour et c'était très
drôle finalement bon c'était une femme
exceptionnelle c'est une grande dame
c'est une grande comédienne parce que je
pense qu'on lui a pas rendu hommage
comme il aurait fallu le faire et
j'avais envie de le faire
et ça me fait bien plaisir
alors
ce qui est terrible pendant toute votre
enfance en fait c'est que le sujet
michel sardou chez vous êtes un tabou
c'est à dire qu'on n'en parle pas sauf
pour dire que c'est un abruti ou alors
quand il passe à la télé aux arbres donc
en plus vous vivez dans le déni de votre
père pendant toute votre enfance et
votre adolescence oui je dis rond
on était on nous a fait aussi du
bourrage de crâne pendant très longtemps
et ça je le il faut être il faut le dire
aussi et donc effectivement quand vous
avez du bourrage de crâne dans tout ça
vous il était fait c'est normal qu'elle
a au bout du compte vous budget bon ben
ok bah non quoi c'est effectivement ça
peut
ça ça du jeu ça gâche les relations quoi
qu'il arrive je disais en commençant que
votre livre était extrêmement
bouleversant parce que vous vivez et
finalement dans cette maison où on
critique votre père sans arrêt quand
vous voyez votre père et vous traite de
tas de merde et pour vos 12 ans votre
beau-père vous roue de coups carrément
vous êtes complètement recroquevillé
tout ça donc à un moment évidemment on
est on sait très bouleversant cette
histoire on souffre pour vous quand vous
êtes dans l'incapacité de bouger et
quand vous effectivement vous êtes au
sol et que vous pouvez pas bougé pendant
un temps la seule larme qui vous restent
si votre esprit et c'est ce qui s'est
produit également dans la tentative de
meurtre hier que votre mental quand je
oui il reste que ça pour finalement
trouver pour garder pour rester en vie
c'est un instinct de survie est ce que
votre beau-père il boude pas parce que
vous recevez des copines en pantoufles
par exemple moi je me suis demandée
sincèrement ce que je faisais là je
n'avais rien à faire là et c'est logique
vous partez un moment donné parce qu'il
n'ya pas yaya rien à faire y'a rien à
alors justement cynthia quand vous
partez pour pour faire des études tout
ça vous vous apercevez qu'en fait le
fric que michel sardou donne à votre
mère votre beau-père le garde pour lui
donc en plus j'ai même pas les moyens de
faire des études on va vous être
complètement bloqué vous à vous avez je
me suis offert une année super j'ai
voulu le faire j'ai travaillé pour ça
j'ai travaillé pour payer mes études et
finalement même si c'était pas
énorme et j'ai fait ce que j'ai pu ouais
tout simplement vous êtes courageuse
c'est vrai et malgré tout un moment vous
pensez à vous suicider quand même oui
effectivement
et c'est un clochard je te soumets par
une page un alcoolique mais sauve la vie
c'est formidable formidable c'est
formidable alors vous commencez à vous
en sortir vous commencé à bosser jackie
sardou vous faire entrer chez daniel
filipacchi comme maître d'hôtel est
excellente et sympa j'ai filipacchi
assez
bien tous très bien voilà vous fait des
petits boulots des petits jobs vous
commencez à vous intégrer à la société
vous commencez à exister vous travaillez
à i télévision donc qu est une filiale
info du groupe canal plus et là un soir
voilà vous quittez vous quittez
itélévision vous rentrez chez vous et
dans le parking de votre immeuble vous
êtes carrément enlever
par trois mecs j'ai été suivie en
voiture et puis j'ai été enlevée dans ma
voiture
oui
trois mecs qui vont vous violez pendant
pendant deux heures on m'a enlevé
séquestré avec un couteau bien sûr enfin
couteau est pas loin en tout cas
et puis bon ben j'ai jeu et en plus je
sais même pas où on m'emmène je sais pas
ce qui va m'arriver
effectivement on peut s'attendre à tout
parce que quand on voit les visages le
visage d'un criminel et qu'on peut le
reconnaître effectivement
d'ailleurs j'étais à deux doigts
d'exploser dans mon auto donc oui
c'était alors à ce moment-là votre mec
vous lâche et un moment sardou pour vous
rejoindre à ce moment-là à un accrochage
dans le tunnel de la défense et se
brisent le match là c'est vraiment un un
enchaînement de choses absolument
absolument terrible et et vous vous
trouver refuge en fait chez michel
sardou qui vient de se remarier donc
pour la pour la troisième fois avec anne
marie périer vous commencez à vivre un
peu chez eux c'est lui qui vous le
propose en fait fait et au bout d'un
moment il vous le reproche oui
oui effectivement il ya un juste un mois
tout juste après les faits j'avais quand
même dans le sang
un traitement du vih qui est quand même
difficile à supporter parce qu'en plus
j'ai repris le travail dix jours après
et je suis retourné à la chaîne j'ai
très bon j'étais en traitement
thérapeutique est effectivement j'avais
toujours dans l'est dans ma tête je me
demandais si j'allais avoir le sida ou
pas
effectivement je
oui j'étais donc je travaillais à la
chaîne je rentrais le soir et tout ça et
puis effectivement il ya un bien
un matin j'ai été j'ai eu
effectivement une engueulade avec mon
père en privé et g
j on m'a foutu dehors quoi mafuta qui
vous reprochent de squatter non
seulement son appartement mais sa femme
et puisqu'à pire que tout ce qui vous
dit que vous mangez du poisson et que ça
lui coûte plus cher que la viande ça
j'avoue que ça m'a complètement mais je
peux pas manger de viande serait
impossible pour moi je ne pouvais pas
parce que suite au fait c'était
impossible cela et parce que je
je ne forçait pas jeu je me suis forcée
en plus de ça parce qu'il m'a quand même
fait manger de la viande je ne dis pas
mais c'est pas grave ouais alors il vous
dit que vous êtes nuls que votre
thérapie c'est de la merde enfin
vraiment on peut pas dire qu'ils qui
vous aide et ce qui est extraordinaire
dans cette histoire c'est qu'en fait
vous en auriez pas parlé on l'aurait
jamais susi a que tous les journaux tous
les magazines français les radios les
télévisions ont accepté de ne pas parler
de votre de votre viol
est alors lui en fait il va pas au
procès
justement pour pas qu'on en parle mais
n'agit je ne demandais pas ce qu'il soit
là parce qu'effectivement la presse
aurait pu attirer il aurait pu attirer
l'attention de la presse justement en
revanche un coup de téléphone ou un
petit mot gentil avec un bouquet de
fleurs ça fait de mal à personne
alors vos agresseurs sont condamnés à 15
13 et 10 ans de prison ce qui est plutôt
plutôt bien non plutôt pas mal
maintenant votre père qui a toujours
parlé de faire justice lui même qui a
toujours dit qu'il était pour la peine
de mort il à laisser la justice faire
son travail sans intervenir sur ce coup
là
effectivement
alors quelles ont été les réactions de
michel sardou à votre livre il a eu une
très bonne réaction il a très bien réagi
à ça et c'est plutôt agréable à entendre
et jeu je suis ravi ravi bosch dans
l'eure
j'en sais rien il a dit qu'il
reconnaissait qu'il n'avait pas été un
bon père d'une certaine façon et huawei
est ce que vous pensez pas que michel
sardou s'est comporté comme ça avec vous
parce que lui aussi a été finalement il
n'a pas eu ses parents il était en
pension moncel il voyait rarement son
père armand sa mère est peut-être ça ne
l'a pas habitué à être un bon père d'une
certaine façon non c'est pas juan veut
même pas d'avoir été absent non moi je
parce que je ne lui en veux pas d'avoir
été absent parce qu'un artiste déjà ne
se comporte pas comme quelqu'un de
normal c'est pas quelqu'un de normal un
artiste un artiste c'est quelqu'un n'a
pas d'à par différents des autres qui
est qui reste dans une eau
qui est solitaire et donc je ne lui en
veut pas d'eux
d'avoir été absent parce que je sais
qu'il a donné ce qu'il fallait donc je
lui en veux pas pour ça d'ailleurs je
lui en veux pour rien moi je suis parti
et je j'avais des raisons très
personnelles de le faire et d'ailleurs
j'ai écrit cède ce témoignage parce que
j'ai eu d'autres pressions aux états
unis et que j'en ai eu assez et quelle
pression je vais aussi j'ai eu des coups
de fil désagréable et j'en ai pas ce que
j'avais écrit ce témoignage au départ
pour moi et j'en ai eu assez de
supporter parce que tout ça ça fait
remonter la peur et mon passé et j'en ai
eu assez je me suis dit que les gens
avaient le droit de savoir ouais c'est
tout vous l'avez vu pour la dernière
fois michel star d'eau
gelée vu il ya deux ans et demi c'était
juste avant mon départ aux états unis
ouais pas de but au théâtre
que jude est urgent j'ai ici et vous a
téléphoné depuis l'apparition du livre
non
vous pensez que ce livre va aider ou à
graver votre relation avec lui déjà n'y
a pas de relation pour l'instant donc il
n'ya pas de dialogue effectivement et
d'ailleurs je ne cherche pas en avoir
moi j'ai fait un choix je suis parti
parce que c'était la seule façon de m'en
sortir
maintenant je vous dis sincèrement que
si je continue à être embêté là-bas et
si on continue
je vais pas non plus pousser loin les
pressions mais j'irai jusqu'au bout
vous regrettez pas de pas lui avoir dit
tout ça de vive voix plutôt qu'à travers
un livre à votre père j'ai essayé de le
faire plusieurs fois et
ça il n'y a pas de dialogue le dialogue
ne passe pas est ce qu'après ce livre
vous êtes prête pour une nouvelle vie a
complètement complètement c'est un
tournage de pages quoi complet mais j'ai
déjà tourné la page moi je suis déjà
passé à autre chose depuis un moment
j'ai reconstruit donc ailleurs et je
j'ai des projets je travaille sur des
jeux plusieurs choses en même temps
j'ai des tas de j'ai envie de
croquer la vie à pleines dents moi j'ai
envie de me marier
fonder une famille cynthia bien sûr mais
en pensez quoi tu sois en histoire oriel
je ne sais pas mais votre grand mère
jackie sardou qui semblait une personne
tellement adorable et truculente ne
pouvez pas vous vous aider dans la
sphère elle a fait le faire bien sûr
mais mais jusqu'à un certain point quoi
elle ne pouvait pas faire en sorte que
son fils intéresse un peu mieux à vous
certainement mais ça n'a pas visiblement
ça n'a pas fonctionné
parce que je suis je les aime mes
parents je les relis pages remis
personne sauf que il ya un moment il ya
plus passe rien qu'est ce que vous
voulez faire qu'est ce que vous voulez
faire je veux dire il n'ya pas il n'y a
pas d'issue vous pouvez pas changer les
gens monsieur le ministre le mot de la
fin non je sache un peu gêné par don de
vous le dire parce que je crois que dans
les affaires privées vraiment quand il
s'agit de la vie des couples la vie
amoureuse des gens la vie affective
avec ses parents personnes non seulement
ne de juger mais personne n'a le droit
de juger on peut pas dire qu'on dise des
vérités ya pas de vérité dans ces
affaires-là quand des gens sait pas
quand des gens se fâchent entre parents
enfants 36 proches que ça entre mari et
femme personne n'a le droit ni le
pouvoir de savoir ce qui s'est passé
vraiment et donc je suis au fond ce que
vous dites là il faut probablement c'est
à lui que vous le dit d'ailleurs mais
faut le dire votre père peut-être à
votre analystes mais au fond je faciaux
qui est vraiment du courage à le publier
je suis pas sûr que ce soit bon pour
vous voilà mais bon il faudrait en
parler un peu plus longuement mais dans
ces affaires-là ne croyez pas que
personne ne pense qu'on puisse dire or
il est mauvais il a tort il a raison la
pauvre le méchant on peut jamais savoir
comment ça se passe peut-être que ce que
vous dites est entièrement vrai mais de
toute façon moi je ne le saurai jamais
personne ici ne pourra jamais juger et
d'anti peut-être sont des choses qu'il
faut le dire à lui mais pas mais pas aux
autres et je suis toujours un peu gêné
la sphère privée s'étale en public alors
que bon voila vous livrer sa aux siens
si je puis dire à des gens qui vont dire
du mal de lui dira c'est un [ __ ] mais
personne n'en saura jamais rien ici oui
mais c'est votre affaire c'est avec lui
sous les faut régler ça avec son père
n'est pas que les autres sont sardou est
très secondaire dans mon histoire quand
enfin si c'était pas lui on n'en
parlerai pas ici
pas sûr mais aussi six ans à riadh
hennouni
rajouter quelque chose oui moi je
voulais m'excuser auprès de vous si
j'étais peut-être un peu comme ça un peu
brutale un peu choquant mais c'est parce
que c'est gentil mais c'est juste parce
que apparemment oui et puis on sent une
vraie souffrance chez vous non
simplement que j'ai vraiment peur qu'en
passant du très privé comme ça au public
vous soyez extrêmement déçu après parce
que le jugement des autres a
probablement aucun rapport avec ce que
vous avez vécu en tout cas n'attendez
pas deux qui comprenne forcément ce que
vous disiez ou qu'ils puissent être
jugés en a fait assez vrai que quand on
écrit un livre et qu'on le déchirent pas
après c'est quand même qu'on a besoin
d'eux des autres pour comprendre pour
juger ce qu'on a vécu quand c'est des
affaires très privée je crois qu on
risque d'être de se tromper d'être déçu
voilà c'est ce qu'à ça je voulais vous
dire sur tout mais pas ses points
méchanceté vous répondre simplement que
le crime n'a pas de visage et que quel
que soit le contexte social vous vous
soyez le crime arrive n'importe où
n'importe quand et qu'il n'y a pas de
lieu
et en revanche il n'y a pas de
mais
tout peut arriver dans une existence
tout est possible et rien n'est
impossible dans le cours d'une existence
et c'est ça le message
merci et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de nos latitudes abonnez vous y mettez
un peu de bleu